[Music]
hey guys daniel rossen for the scoring
sports with the 2019 League of Legends
World Championships coming up we want to
take a look back and make a list of what
we consider to be the best worlds plays
of all time now you might remember that
we did a list similar to this a few
years ago but we thought is about time
for an update so let's get on to what
you actually came here to see the best
worlds plays of all time kicking off our
list at number 10 is a rapid stars
requiem quadric Hill from Game one of
the season 2 World Championship finals
trailing in the early game against
perennial underdogs Taipei assassins
cloudtemplar found TPA with a clutch
four-man curse of the sad mummy
but the barrage of CC wasn't enough to
stop TPA who looked strong enough to
endure and win the fight
[Applause]
but it was a rapid stars positioning
that allowed him to drown the enemy in
his defile when he finally went down
what else could he do but hit that big
red Requiem button neatly securing a
quadric hill with a little added help
from a delight azubu began to claw back
into the game off the back of this fight
eventually winning in 40 minutes coming
in at number nine is cement pulling the
trigger on the cleanest slicing
maelstrom in the history of Pro League
of Legends
it was in the group stage of worlds 2016
where the stars align off the back of a
shoddy engage from g2 now anyone else
might have been hesitant to faced I have
a team of four alone but as the best
player of the tournament
smeb knew that this fight was already
over
[Applause]
viii proved game-changing as it swung
the gold lead into Roxas favor and they
closed up the game in a convincing
fashion takes over the team fight there
are few things better than a legend
showing that he's still God which is why
we have the best 1v1 in world history
coming in at number 8 da de was seen as
the best player from the best region
heading into Worlds 2014 where a speck a
was seen as being on the decline so when
he came face to face against da de he
had a little something to prove
especially when you consider that Pekka
was using dades best champion da de
found expec 8 with his pants down and in
2014's assassin meta everyone thought he
had expect a dead to rights
but a perfectly timed death Mark II
cheeky flash and a stroke of luck
ohad Pekka to survive with a sliver of
health fight Steph just finishes well
fnatic short 2014 world's run spelled
the end of expect his tenure with the
team this one play proved that he could
still stand alongside the best
coming in at number 7 on our list is imp
and modest 2v3 against AHQ from the 2014
World Championship Samsung white went
into 2014 worlds as one of the Korean
favorites and a big reason for that was
that they're bottling imp and mato were
dubbed the best bottling in the world
and it didn't take long for them to
prove that they were worthy of the
moniker this was a play so perfect that
it looks script a true display of skill
and teamwork on the fly white went on to
win the entire tournament but no single
play was more representative of imp and
modest skill than this out coming in at
number 6 on our list is huni's riven
quadric hill from world's 2015 from the
beginning of this fight the odds were
against fnatic both tepees from the top
lane came in as Kakao approached for a
gank IG had the extra man and by all
accounts should have won the fight even
with both sides enduring only one death
who nee could have cut his losses and
ran away but he saw something that no
one else did
[Applause]
wellthen annex 2015 world's run and that
faster than they had hoped a young hooni
showed the world he's a true menace on
the rift and no one plays shows that
better than this one at number five on
our list we have the shy and his 1v5
aatrox engage against g2 and the
semi-finals of worlds 2018
after losing ning in a dragon pit fight
IG were at a disadvantage and attempted
to disengage the fight the shy however
had his own plans and gifted fans with
one of the best balls-to-the-wall
engages in league history they already
got to pick on the enemy the shy single
handedly eviscerated the health bars of
three g2 members giving IG the green
light to come back in and clean up
shines everyone they're rookies the
lan-evo rookie back to the double kill
for himself he cleans up birthday
tragedy strikes
the EU LCS Representatives
going into season three's World
Championship there were whispers of a
young Chinese ad carry whose mechanics
alone would make him the best in the
world and at the number four spot on our
list is V play that put you on the map
Susie's coming from the bite site
surprise here comes the babe kill for
white Samsung can escape this one they
focused our Uzi look at him the now
iconic play happened in only his second
match of the tournament against Chinese
rivals OMG woozi found his team engaged
on in the jungle and in a prime position
to flank the ad carry did not miss his
opportunity at number three on our list
is an insane 2v4 from world's 2016
courtesy of prey and peanut in Game
three of their semi-final series SKT saw
fight that on paper should have gone
their way with Kuro smeb and gorilla
falling any other team would have cut
their losses and run away instead of
turning prey and peanut decided to take
the fight to SKT amongst all the
disadvantages and variables prey and
peanut used aggression and raw mechanics
to create a moment that no one could
ever forget prey does he find the
targets Tina has guardian angel maybe he
plays frontline how much can they really
get
what else kitty cat it's gonna be Blake
in his sights
[Applause]
baker's low how much for can they get
this done scum again
[Applause]
control this game another play from that
legendary 2016 rocks vs. SKT series
Harless just wouldn't be complete
without praise cross map crystal arrow
which is why it comes into the number 2
spot on our list in a jaw-dropping game
two rocks found themselves in a
situation to potentially in the game
with SKT in full retreat and pray and
Kuro breathing down their necks Duke
decided that a teleport back to base was
the best option to save the game Frey
had other plans however and launched an
insane cross map arrow to stop Duke dead
in his tracks back on towards prey push
back yet again but Spencer
with Joe
[Applause]
series atop our list we have a ruler
conquering the SKT dynasty with a
perfect chain of corruption on the king
himself and quite simply there's no play
in world's history as good as this one
with a world championship sized chip on
their shoulders samsung galaxy dominated
SKT in the first two games of their 2017
world's final series but in Game three
the defending champs came out of the
gate strong Samsung clawed their way
back to even gold with SKT but ruler
took things into his own hands
and the rest as they say is League of
Legends history
[Applause]
Kings says Galaxy your 2017 champions
and that's our list do you think that
there's a world's play that we left off
that deserves to be on the list make
sure to hit us up in the comments and
let us know don't forget to like the
video subscribe the channel and we'll
see you next time thanks for watching if
you want more content like this hit the
sub button and ring that notification
bell for unique bite-sized videos you
won't find anywhere else hit up art
Instagram Twitter and Facebook pages